hey what is up guys mkbhd here and it's
the end of 2013 and now smart watches
are becoming a thing so this one here is
the samsung galaxy gear it's the first
smart watch from samsung
and it's probably that smart watch he
saw in some commercials somewhere but it
was a pretty good commercial but the
first generation of a product you see
out of a company is usually the one you
want to pay the most attention to
especially the first product in a new
product category like smart watches so
this is the one we're gonna put under
the microscope first let's take a full
detailed look at the samsung galaxy gear
at first glance the galaxy gear appears
to be just slightly different from your
normal watch but samsung is calling it
the next big thing so this is their
first in wearable tech and they've
decided to put it on your wrist as an
accessory to your phone and it'll
connect via bluetooth so as a watch this
is actually quite well built it's a
solid rigid plastic band all the way
around and a pretty nice clasp design
that's adjustable to fit even the most
extreme wrist sizes like mine and the
watch part itself is actually pretty
compact it doesn't stand out or look as
ridiculous as you might think the only
button on the entire device is the power
button on the right hand side which can
be programmed to do certain things when
you double tap it but a single tap will
turn the display on or off and
surrounding the whole face of the watch
is surprise metal real metal from
samsung so that's good news and of
course on the actual face of the watch
instead of the regular analog mechanics
it is a 1.6 inch 320 by 320 oled display
and it's actually objectively very nice
it has a 275 ppi pixel density and great
bright vivid colors it has an outdoor
mode for enhanced brightness so you can
see it everywhere
and excellent viewing angles so you can
see it indoors outdoors pretty much
whenever you want it's really nice
display on the back you have these pins
which you'll need to connect to the dock
for the galaxy gear which is actually
necessary it comes in the box and you
need it for the nfc pairing setup for
the first time and for every time you
charge it so every time you want to
charge your galaxy gear you have to hook
it up to this clasp dock which has that
lovely faux leather stitching that we
love so much and then you'll plug it in
now around the bottom of the watch
there's another metal piece that sits
below your wrist and unfortunately this
is the only part of the watch that feels
a bit bulky and like actually sometimes
gets in the way so when i'm resting my
wrist on something or trying to type it
kind of gets annoying but there's a
reason for this metal piece here there
are actually more electronics in there
if you hold it up to the light you can
actually see the electronics wiring
going down into the metal clasp turns
out this metal clasp contains the
speakerphone yes that's a speakerphone
in the bottom so you don't actually have
to hold the watch up to your face like a
weirdo to talk on the phone you can just
talk and it'll hear you but you do have
to hold it like a total weirdo however
if you want to take pictures with it
like this because uh that's a camera
yeah the bulge on the galaxy gear is a
camera um
questionable choice of a feature to add
on a watch but hey it's there it's a two
megapixel sensor and it can take square
photos that actually you know they look
half decent for a watch and the year can
also record up to 15 seconds of 720p
video and i've noticed that the
microphone quality since it's meant to
be meant for phone calls and a
speakerphone it's pretty good you can
get an idea of the video quality here
it's definitely not bad but at its heart
this is an android device android 4.2 to
be specific and sometimes it's really
obvious but other times not so much
thanks of course to samsung's skin that
they've overlaid on here that shows one
app per page but it's powered by a
single core 800 megahertz processor half
a gig of ram and it even has four gigs
of internal storage and it's packing a
315 milliamp hour battery to put that
into perspective this watch actually has
very similar computing power to the
original motorola droid back in the day
which was a very sizable device but it
has a battery way less than a quarter of
the size and because of that it can only
really promise you one full day of
actual use and you might be able to eat
two days out of it if you really don't
use it all that much standby time is
great but at the end of the day you're
going to have to charge it every single
night and as a watch person that's
usually something people don't have to
do with a watch so it's a really big
annoyance if you're used to well only
charging one device every night instead
of two but really though what can the
galaxy gear do that's the number one
question people have about it when they
see it well okay number one it can give
you notifications from your phone
they're pretty useless though because
they don't actually tell you anything
they just tell you that you have a
notification on your phone which means
you have to go check your phone anyway
it's kind of pointless it's better with
some built-in samsung apps like the
samsung mail app and samsung stock
messenger but not everyone really uses
those next up there is s voice to give
you commands to your phone which should
in theory let you call people and text
people from your wrist but s voice is
still s voice and the speech recognition
is a bit shoddy and it doesn't always
work all the time you can take voice
memos and save them to your phone which
is nice and you also have the gallery
which lets you take pictures and
transfer them to your samsung phone or
even share them directly from supported
apps in the samsung store which we'll
get to in a second there's a midi
controller which is actually very useful
it allows you to control the volume and
media playback in like any media app
like youtube spotify soundcloud whatever
so you can control your music while
keeping your phone in your pocket and
then there is a pedometer to keep track
of your fitness and distance traveled
and calories burned i can also talk to
the s health app on your samsung phone
so wearable tech right now really seems
to be specializing in fitness which can
be really cool also side note the
pedometer isn't very accurate i mean
it's on your wrist so you can walk with
your hands in your pockets and they'll
somewhat sync up but if you don't then
this is a step and this is a step and
this is a step and
i'm walking what and then there's the
contacts the call log and the dialer so
you can place and receive calls on the
speakerphone on your watch on your wrist
which is what samsung has really been
harping up in their commercials and i
gotta say this feature works perfectly
it basically turns your phone into a
bluetooth speaker
might not be the coolest thing in public
when everyone can hear your phone call
but when the phone is in another room
and maybe bluetooth is still connected
you can pick up an incoming call without
running to go find your phone and lastly
there is a mini app store that samsung
has kickstarted for the galaxy gear and
the list of apps in that app store is
definitely not very large and there
aren't even that many categories but
then again it's a watch and hey there
are some nice apps in there there are
some interesting somewhat usefully
functional apps like the watch face
applications i really like them because
they let me actually mess around with
the galaxy gears watch face in real time
so that's nice but the rest of them are
basically miniaturized versions of
bigger titles like evernote or snapchat
and there are some pretty big gaps that
should obviously be filled later this is
literally a brand new app store so it
doesn't take
any sort of cues from google play at all
but that's something developers are
going to have to fill in the apps on
finding and liking for the galaxy gear
are mostly oh why didn't i think of that
ideas like stuff like that could really
seem like a smart watch is worth getting
but just because you can't do it on any
other form factor doesn't mean you
actually need to right now it seems like
a case of google glass where the app
store doesn't immediately matter it's
more just about warming people up to the
core functionality of a device with this
new form factor and then letting the app
store grow and seeing what developers
can do with it now up to this point you
may have realized hey this is all being
done through a samsung app on a samsung
device and you'd be totally right this
is actually only compatible with a
samsung android device running android
4.3 or later and there are only two of
those right now the galaxy note 3 and
the galaxy note 10.1 tablet and soon the
galaxy s4 and the galaxy note 2 but it's
a very small portion of all the devices
out there and that is easily the galaxy
gear's biggest limitation and biggest
fault or problem at this point and it
even looks worse when you compare it to
its natural competitor which would be
the pebble smart watch right now which
is compatible with just about any smart
watch that has bluetooth so the biggest
limitation to the galaxy gear right now
physically is the compatibility so at
the end of the day the galaxy gear is
definitely a very polarizing and
somewhat confusing device just because
it's unclear who exactly was going to
buy something like this because when you
consider the watch enthusiasts already
who already all have watches they're not
going to spend 300 on something that's
like this but if you consider the tech
enthusiasts who always use their phones
why would they put something on their
wrist so if you're on the fence about
buying something like this i would say
at least wait for the price to drop
because it will mark my words but if you
want to keep waiting the galaxy gear 2
is probably going to be a better option
or you could wait from the other
smartwatch manufacturers because
google's probably going to come out with
one apple's probably going gonna come
out with one sony's probably gonna come
out with one and many many more so
there's definitely some future things to
look forward to but since samsung did it
first this is what they can call their
pioneer and they can take all the credit
for being the first one in the market
with it but i can't really recommend it
for everyone i can only really recommend
it for someone who just has to have it
as a sort of a companion or accessory to
your galaxy phone so this is a good
entry it's a good beginning and it's a
good start and a good sign for the
future of smart watches and it's
definitely got me excited for what we're
gonna see when google takes a stab at it
and many more companies get their game
on with smartwatch and other wearable
tech either way that's been it thank you
for this watching this video i hope you
enjoyed it i hope you enjoyed the review
and if you're excited for more there's a
subscribe button below you can tap or
you can just hit that like button show
your appreciation but the comments
section is what's most important it's
open below if you have any questions
feel free to drop them right there this
has been mkbhd thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
one
peace
you